Au cours des cinq dernières années, je me suis réveillé et c'est
comme quelque chose qui s'est accéléré au-delà de mon
contrôle,
vous pouvez parier que certains d'entre vous savent probablement
que Max a eu un mariage vers le sud
prématurément, mais celui-ci ressemble à
tous les systèmes, bien sûr que l'autre
pourrait bien avoir  ressemblait à ça au
début eh bien essayons
et nous verrons qui donne en premier je suis
comme une valise mexicaine tu penses à
Johnny Depp pour avoir un orgasme vraiment
tu te remaries ne dis rien à ta
femme  tu penses à des
célébrités
je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de remarquer que tu es dans mon
entreprise aujourd'hui puis-je t'offrir une coupe de
champagne commençant à penser que nous devrions
nous renvoyer il est terrible
comme si tu ne savais pas de quoi tu parlais
ouais je ne laisse pas ça m'arrêter
[Musique]